[Música]
11 colecciones de documentos
clasificados fueron halladas en la
residencia de florida del ex presidente
de donald trump en el allanamiento
realizado por el fbi y se encontraron
incluso documentos ultras secretos por
lo que se investigará hacia el ex
mandatario violó la ley de espionaje
hay alerta en nueva york' tras
identificar el virus que causa la
poliomielitis en las aguas residuales de
la ciudad estas semanas después de que
se conociera el primer caso de polio
registrado en 10 años las autoridades
pidieron a los ciudadanos que se vacunen
la deforestación de la amazonía
brasileña creció un 32% en julio
comparado con el mes anterior en lo que
se considera la mayor pérdida de selva
registrada desde enero de este año mil
486 kilómetros cuadrados de vegetación
nativa fueron devastados en ese periodo
bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
eeuu porque el departamento de justicia
informó que decenas de documentos
confidenciales fueron encontrados en mar
al lago la residencia de verano del ex
presidente de donald trump en el sur de
la florida
la justicia estadounidense indicó que
algunos archivos están clasificados como
ultra secretos por lo que no pueden ser
sustraídos de las oficinas del gobierno
federal es por ello que la fiscalía
alega una posible violación de la ley de
espionaje por parte del ex mandatario
luz sobre una de las operaciones
policiales más impactantes contra un ex
presidente en eeuu estos documentos
publicados este viernes por el fbi son
el registro de los documentos incautados
el lunes en la residencia del antiguo
mandatario donald trump en mal halago
florida la oficina federal de
investigación confirma la especulación
de los medios estadounidenses trump si
se llevó documentos clasificados de la
casa blanca a su residencia vacacional
que le sirve y asegura que entre las 11
colecciones de documentos que se
incautaron figura información ultra
secreta es decir una alegoría especial
de información sensible trump lo había
negado previamente no necesitaban
incautar nada lo podrían haber hecho en
cualquier momento en el que quisieran
sin hacer política e irrumpir en mar a
lago ahora el fbi confirma que está
investigando a trump por una posible
violación de la ley de espionaje entre
otros dos posibles delitos federales es
un caso sobre el que apenas este jueves
el fiscal general de maryland entregó
detalles y está sacudiendo la política
de la unión americana
todo el mundo está a la expectativa
sobre decir la naturaleza de estos
documentos es lo que aparenta entonces
sería algo muy grave según el washington
post los agentes federales estaban
buscando documentos relacionados con
armas nucleares en la residencia de
trump mientras eso se esclarece en el
horizonte aparece la pregunta de si en
caso de ser hallado culpable champ
quedaría inhabilitado para volverse a
presentar a las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024 continuamos en
eeuu donde la cámara de representantes
aprobó la llamada ley de reducción de la
inflación una normativa emblemática para
los demócratas que contempla efectos
fiscales y una enorme inversión en la
lucha contra el cambio climático en el
que se considera el mayor paquete
climático en la historia de ese país la
ley pone a disposición unos 430 mil
millones de dólares que serán invertidos
además en reducir los precios de los
medicamentos recetados a mayores de 65
años la iniciativa ya contaba con la luz
verde del senado y sólo falta la firma
del presidente yo bailé
las autoridades sanitarias de nueva
york- e identificaron el virus que causa
la poliomielitis en las aguas residuales
de la ciudad e instaron a los
neoyorquinos a vacunarse el anuncio se
produce semanas después de que se
hiciera público el primer caso de polio
en un adulto registrado en casi 10 años
ariana villacorta nos amplia
crece la preocupación de las autoridades
sanitarias neoyorquinas el departamento
de salud de la ciudad confirmó el
hallazgo del virus que produce la
poliomielitis en las aguas residuales lo
que sugiere una mayor circulación del
mismo y lanzaron advertencias la
poliomielitis puede provocar parálisis e
incluso la muerte instamos a los
neoyorquinos no vacunados a vacunarse
ahora el anuncio se produce semanas
después de que se hiciera público un
caso de polio en un adulto en el condado
de rockland donde al igual que en el
condado de orange la tasa de vacunación
contra el virus es asombrosamente baja
sólo alrededor del 60% se ha inoculado
contra la enfermedad en estas zonas en
comparación con el 93 por ciento en todo
el país esto porque ahí vive una
importante comunidad ortodoxa que afirma
que las vacunas van en contra de la ley
judía aún así las autoridades de nueva
york- están abriendo centros de
vacunación para evitar la propagación de
la poliomielitis que suele ser
asintomática que no tiene cura y que se
ha cobrado miles de vidas
la poliomielitis había sido una
preocupación extraordinaria con cientos
de miles de casos y decenas de miles de
muertes durante el periodo de tiempo
hasta la introducción de la vacuna salk
momento en el que hubo un cambio
dramático de lo que llamaríamos la
eliminación del control y luego
esencialmente la erradicación
a finales de la década de 1940 los
brotes de poliomielitis incapacitaban a
un promedio de más de 35.000 personas al
año en eeuu afectando principalmente a
niños de 3 años o menos pero a raíz de
la campaña de vacunación en 1955 los
casos disminuyeron rápidamente
el nuevo gobierno colombiano y la
guerrilla de lln oficializaron desdecuba
la reanudación de las conversaciones de
paz detenidos desde 2019 iván danilo
rueda alto comisionado para la paz
aseguró en la capital cubana que hay una
voluntad real para lograr una paz total
estable duradera y sostenible el
secretario general de naciones unidas
antonio guterres respaldo la decisión
del ejecutivo y celebró los esfuerzos
para expandir la paz en colombia' se
trata de una de las promesas de campaña
del presidente gustavo petro que tomó
posesión el pasado domingo este gobierno
anuncia oficialmente
que reconoce la legitimidad de la
delegación de diálogos del ejército de
liberación nacional
en la búsqueda de la paz
en consecuencia el gobierno de colombia
adoptará todas las medidas políticas y
jurídicas en el marco del derecho
interno y el derecho internacional para
garantizar las condiciones que permitan
el reinicio de las conversaciones con el
pn incluido el reconocimiento de los
protocolos el instituto nacional de
investigaciones espaciales de brasil
reveló cifras alarmantes sobre la
deforestación en la amazonía de ese país
desde enero de este año han sido
deforestados más de 5 mil kilómetros
cuadrados de selva tropical un 7% más
que en el mismo periodo del año pasado
proyectos de infraestructura y actividad
ganadera aparecen como los principales
causantes de la deforestación que
propicia incendios ampliamos en el
siguiente informe
la amazonía brasileña en llamas
estas imágenes marcan el inicio el pico
tradicional de la temporada anual de
incendios en esta región del país las
llamas podrían agravarse debido a la
falta de zonas húmedas en la selva como
consecuencia de la deforestación
lamentablemente los incendios nos
sorprenden ante la deforestación que
vivimos en julio llegó a 1.487
kilómetros cuadrados es el mismo nivel
que el año pasado
en lo corrido del año han sido
deforestados más de 5 mil kilómetros
cuadrados de bosque equivalente a un
área siete veces mayor al tamaño de la
ciudad de nueva york pero el gobierno de
jair bolsonaro no toma cartas en el
asunto para frenar la crisis ambiental
para los ambientalistas las políticas de
bolsonaro sólo empeoran la deforestación
hay una política gubernamental
deliberada para reducir la acción de los
órganos gubernamentales de control
ambiental en las áreas ambientales esto
ha sido cubierto por los medios tenemos
números de reducción de presupuesto y de
disminución de acciones en el campo
sobre ello en julio el ministerio de
ambiente de brasil otorgó un permiso
inicial que permitiría la construcción
de una carretera a través del centro de
la selva tropical a esto se suma la
falta de regulación por parte de las
autoridades a la actividad ganadera uno
de los principales sectores causantes de
la tala de árboles a menos de dos meses
de las elecciones presidenciales el
gobierno de bolsonaro pasa a la historia
como la gestión en la que anualmente más
de 10.000 kilómetros cuadrados de bosque
se deforestaron en la región considerada
como el pulmón del mundo el
vicepresidente de paraguay hugo
velásquez anunció que presentará su
renuncia al cargo y también a su
precandidatura presidencial esto luego
de que el departamento de estado
estadounidense lo sancionará a él y al
asesor jurídico de la hidroeléctrica
yacyretá juan carlos duarte acusándolos
de participación en actos de corrupción
y les impidiera el ingreso al país
finalizamos en el zoológico de oakland
en california que le dio la bienvenida a
un punto del sur que se considera el
ciervo más pequeño del mundo los
responsables informaron que nació el
domingo pasado y hasta el momento se
está adaptando
tranquilamente los poderes del sur
residen en selvas tropicales templadas y
en bosques caducifolios
así llegamos al final de este
informativo ustedes gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]